hello and welcome to another Bitcoin
protocol tutorial video in this video
we're going to be discussing the
simplified payment section of the paper
so with that let's go ahead and get
right on into it it is possible to
verify payments without running a full
network note a user only needs to keep a
copy of the block headers of the longest
proof-of-work chain which he can get by
querying the network nodes until he's
convinced he has the longest chain and
then obtained the merkel branch linking
the transaction to the block it's
time-stamped him he can't check the
transaction for himself but by linking
it to a place in the chain he can see
that the network node has accepted it
and the blocks added after it further
confirm the network has accepted it so
here if you were being paid in Bitcoin
you would only need to wait for node
confirmation which is what you typically
see in transfers where you're waiting
for X confirmations new blocks after all
so further solidify the transfer in the
agreement typically you're waiting for
three confirmations something like that
as such the verification is reliable as
long as the honest nodes control the
network but is more vulnerable if the
network is overpowered by an attacker
while network nodes can verify
transactions for themselves the
simplified method can be fooled by an
attackers fabricated transactions for as
long as the attacker can continue to
overpower the network one strategy to
protect against this would be to accept
alerts from network nodes when they
detect an invalid block prompting the
user software to do something like
download a full block and alerted
transactions to confirm the
inconsistency businesses that receive
frequent payments will probably still
want to run their nodes for more
independent security and quicker
verification now again this is where the
51 attack comes into play if the
majority of CPU power is
firing tool I then the network is
obviously no longer secure
if a 51% attack was used then this
simple method would be easily fooled and
one would want to instead have the full
blockchain the way someone could be
tipped off here is if there is you know
some disagreement among the nodes and a
sort of notification or alert could be
you know thrown out and you could then
download the full chain yourself and see
what the inconsistency is and all that
or you could just wait until there's no
more alert or something like that
there's definitely a lot of things that
you can do here you can have various
security measures taken into place
especially to see you know are there
multiple competing blockchains
you know because that's the whole idea
is the accepted blockchain is the
longest blockchain so as soon as an
attacker takes over let's say you would
relatively quickly have to block chains
that were are very close to each other
and basically almost tied for first
right so anytime you have that you might
want to consider being suspicious of the
network at the moment right also if
there's any disagreement and that kind
of stuff so anyways that's going to
conclude the paint verification section
of the paper hopefully you guys enjoyed
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to leave those below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions until next
time